we're used to seeing Nick Jonas like
this but the 26 year old is looking like
this these days and we gotta say he
looks just as good and the internet
agrees it feels amazing and I'm just
blown away fans are tweeting hilarious
reactions to this pic things like quote
I want to chew on Nick Jonases new love
handles while I fall asleep at night and
I can't stop thinking about that bit of
belly hanging over Nick Jonas is shorts
and this quote Nick Jonas is halfway to
dadbod and I've never been more
attracted to him so good seriously
though he looks great the pics were
snapped while Nick was celebrating wife
Priyanka is 37th birthday on a yacht in
Miami my life is very good right now
earlier this year Nick opened up to été
about his image while promoting ugly
dolls you know I haven't grown up in the
public eye and having experienced my
awkward years in the public eye you get
really used to shake things off and
understanding that your imperfections
make you who you are and connect us all
in a big way I think that was one of the
messages in this movie I connected with
the most was just this thought to bring
this message to the fans about
self-acceptance and self-love and also
the love of others and accepting them
and I think it's a particularly poignant
message right now I'm kind of where we
are in the world and he's always been
real about his body with et I love food
that's part of the problems under the to
enjoy food but I've been good about the
diet this year and staying on top of
things
but for the weight cut you know I did
one recently and it basically just
consists of drinking a lot of water
cutting out sodium my costume is also
pretty heavy so I have to sweating a lot
it's not true no you're gonna be like
I'm getting old it starts with you know
the mind and the body and they're all
connected and when you can get a grasp
on all that I think it's really helpful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]